merci Catherine Dumas de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes sénatrice les
républicains de Paris membres de la
commission des affaires étrangères on va
parler de la loi de programmation
militaire de la situation Ukraine dans
quelques instants mais d'abord hier
Emmanuel Macron est allé à Roubaix pour
rendre hommage à ses trois policiers qui
ont été renversés par un chauffard sous
l'emprise de drogue d'alcool il a
dénoncé le chef de l'État les
comportements irresponsables qui tuent
est-ce qu'il faut les sanctionner plus
sévèrement ces comportements
irresponsables oui hier le président a
rendu hommage au nom de la nation à ces
trois policiers est mort d'une façon
incroyable sont des gens qui c'est vrai
d'abord travaillent pour sauver la vie
des autres et au risque de la leur et là
on le voit c'est évident que c'est fait
ne peuvent pas perdurer mais bien sûr
qu'il faut des sanctions bien sûr qu'il
faut être de plus en plus sévère mais je
crois que le vrai sujet c'est cette
violence qui envahit la société dans
votre portage on entend une infirmière
qui dit
maintenant on a des tas de gestes de
violence elle dit même on nous dit plus
merci donc c'est ça veut dire beaucoup
on voit que dans tous les secteurs il y
a de la violence donc il s'agit pas de
sanctions dans un secteur il s'agit d'un
sujet qui quelque part abîme toute notre
société et il faut trouver des réponses
globales et non pas pour la santé pour
l'école pour laquelle réponse pour vous
je crois que c'est une réponse de
société il faut il faut qu'il y ait une
vraie analyse de ce qui se passe dans
notre société je pense que la réponse
elle part de l'école de l'éducation il
faut qu'on apprenne de nouveau ce que
c'est que le respect qu'on doit pas être
violent qu'on doit respecter l'autre
après donc il y a toute cette éducation
qui n'existe plus les gens ne se parlent
plus respectent plus mais se tape dessus
donc ça c'est pas possible donc ça c'est
des civilisations comme le dit le chef
de l'État c'est le mot qui l'employait
oui alors après je sais pas si c'est le
bon mot d'abord c'est un mot difficile à
dire on le comprend pas forcément je
pense que le sujet c'est pas ça c'est
comment on remédie à ce qui se passe
dans notre société cette violence de
partout surtout le territoire grande
ville petite ville etc et dans tous les
domaines donc ça part de depuis l'école
il faut qu'on réapprenne ce que c'est
que le civisme après il faut bien sûr
une fois qu'on respecte plus les règles
de la société et de la répression et
puis évidemment des sanctions peut-être
plus fortes donc c'est un ensemble et il
faut être conscient que c'est toute la
société qui est concernée et non pas des
secteurs comprend au jour le jour en
fonction de des faits divers on va
continuer à parler de l'actualité on va
voir ça avec nos partenaires de la
presse régionale on va du côté du
Puy-en-Velay on retrouve christorda
Christophe down bonjour Christophe
pardon rédacteur en chef de l'éveil de
la Haute-Loire merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous à ce matin Christophe on va
parler d'une autre actualité avec vous
ce sont les questions de trafic de
drogue
une solution pour faire diminuer la
consommation de drogue il est violence
liée serait justement de s'attaquer aux
consommateurs
bonjour tout d'abord c'est un vrai sujet
et on parle de la violence en début
d'émission on continue avec la violence
et le trafic de drogue c'est évident
vous dites il s'étend à toutes les
villes bien sûr en effet tout le
territoire et la France n'est pas le
seul pays d'ailleurs tout le territoire
est maintenant concerné c'était avant
beaucoup concentré dans les grandes
villes aujourd'hui du fait d'abord que
quelque part l'urbain gagne sur le rural
donc le suburbain fait que tout le monde
est concerné il y a une consommation
vous l'avez dites plus en plus
importante c'est évident il y a aussi
quelque part une production aussi qui
est très très importante il faut le
savoir moi j'ai été récemment à Cayenne
pour une mission qui concernait
l'immigration leur paillage des sujets
autour de l'Amazonie et j'ai pu voir à
la fois à Cayenne qu'il y a de plus en
plus de gens de passeurs la drogue
arrive énormément sur ce territoire de
la France qui a plus en plus de gens qui
essayent de passer de la drogue en
revanche j'ai pu aussi voir ce qui est
quand même plutôt rassurant qui est
énormément de services de police qui
sont là pour arrêter ces passeurs et que
ils y arrivent pour beaucoup donc ça
c'est quand même aussi il y a quand même
des choses qui sont faites par la police
et je pense que la mise à l'intérieur a
fait ce qu'il fallait à Cayenne après en
effet il y a quand même de la drogue qui
arrive en France est-ce que c'est le
consommateur qui doit être sanctionné
oui certainement parce qu'on voit bien
que selon le type de drogue il y a
aujourd'hui quelque part une sorte de
consommation courante je pense à la
cocaïne par exemple qui fait des ravages
on l'a vu avec un certain nombre de
faits divers gravissimes qui fait
beaucoup de ravages donc là oui il faut
certainement beaucoup plus de sanctions
là aussi il faut aussi de l'éducation
expliquer peut-être mieux aux jeunes
notamment ce que le mal que fait la
drogue et puis après il y a d'autres
types de drogues parce qu'il y a
différentes choses dont on parle moi je
joue à Paris on était très concernés par
le sujet du crack on l'est toujours
d'ailleurs et donc ça aussi c'est c'est
encore un autre type de drogue qu'il
faut essayer de de juguler donc
évidemment le consommateur est un acteur
de cette affaire-là et on ne peut pas le
laisser un puni c'est évident autre
sujet dont on va parler avec vous
Christophe c'est le sujet de
l'immigration et notamment cette visite
de Catherine Colonna la mise des
Affaires étrangères du côté de Rome pour
tenter de déjeuner les relations entre
la France et l'Italie sur le sujet
c'est peut-être la fin d'une brouille
diplomatique en tout cas la ministre des
Affaires étrangères elle était hier à
Rome pour rencontrer son homologue
Antonio Tajani alors on le sait les deux
pays sont en froid sur la question de
l'immigration Gérald Darmanin avait
critique la première ministre Georgia
Meloni en la jugeant je cite incapable
de régler les problèmes migratoires sur
lequel elle a été élue alors après cette
visite justement on parle déjà de dégel
entre les deux pays sur le fond quand
même l'Italie reproche toujours à la
France et à ses partenaires européens de
ne pas prendre leur part dans l'accueil
des migrants qui arrivent chez eux après
avoir traversé la Méditerranée alors ma
question Catherine Dumas selon vous
quelle attitude doit adopter la France
sur cette question migratoire
alors une attitude très forte et je vais
vous parler des propositions de mon
parti juste un mot sur l'Italie et ce
qui s'est passé on parle de la fin de la
brouille je l'espère bien parce que
l'Italie c'est un voisin c'est un
partenaire et c'est pas possible en plus
l'Italie elle a
malencontreuse idée d'être situé le plus
proche de l'arrivée de ces migrants dans
la Méditerranée donc forcément c'est
l'Italie qui en reçoit le plus il a eu
tort Gérard Darmanin je dis pas qu'il a
eu tort mais je sais pas si c'était
complètement approprié en tout cas la
preuve puisqu'on parle de bruit et qu'il
faut et qu'il n'y ait plus de bruit donc
et on n'a pas besoin d'une brouille
c'est pas comme ça qu'on va résoudre ces
problèmes donc c'est vrai que la
Méditerranée orientale notamment amène
un flot d'immigration irrégulière
impensable au-delà du drame humain que
ça peut évidemment qui qui existe c'est
pas possible qu'on laisse les choses
perdurer il y a une aujourd'hui une
incapacité il faut le reconnaître de
l'Europe à pouvoir régler ce problème
migratoire c'est c'est le cas
nous en ce qui nous alors Monsieur
Macron nous avait dit je vais travailler
sur le sujet et faire une loi
immigration sécurité on voit bien que
les deux fonctionnent ensemble bientôt
avant l'été de façon à pouvoir trouver
de nouvelles mesures finalement il a
reculé en disant c'est pas le bon moment
est-ce qu'elle sera votée etc après
l'épisode facho des retraites donc c'est
pour ça que au sein des républicains
nous avons repris la main et nous avons
nous déposons de propositions de loi
dont une constitutionnelle et une
ordinaire pour essayer d'apporter un
certain nombre de solutions on se rend
compte en effet que quelque part dans
certains cas sur le sujet migratoire qui
intéresse l'ensemble de l'Europe les
traités européens peuvent être une gêne
pour régler certains problèmes et qu'il
faut aussi que les pays retrouvent leur
souveraineté sur les sujets migratoires
donc c'est le but de notre proposition
de loi faire en sorte que sur des
traités européens Gérald Darmanin devant
vous devant ordinateur il a parlé cru
exit migratoire alors bon je pense qu'il
a été un peu
excessive dans son propos nous notre
sujet c'est quand les enjeux de la
France
sont importants quand il s'agit du sujet
migratoire qu'on retrouve une
souveraineté pour régler certains
problèmes donc et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut modifier la Constitution il faut
savoir que par exemple on veut faire un
référendum sur ces sujets il faut
questionner les Français il faut que les
Français soient des acteurs aussi de ces
sujets ils peuvent pas juste être
passifs nous on voudrait faire un
référendum l'article 11 aujourd'hui ne
le permet pas donc ça par exemple ça
permettrait de modifier et de faire en
sorte qu'il puisse y avoir un référendum
sur les sujets migratoires donc voilà
nous on travaille on amène quelque chose
de très précis qui est assez audacieux
mais aussi réaliste et c'est une façon
de répondre à ces sujets aujourd'hui en
ce qui concerne en tout cas les
républicains
merci Christophe d'avoir été avec nous
Christophe d'armes on regarde la Une de
l'éveil de la Haute-Loire c'est le
prince Albert II elle a une de l'éveil
de la Haute-Loire sur les traces de ses
ancêtres c'est-à-dire dans votre journal
merci Christophe d'armes d'avoir été
avec nous pour nous parler de cette
actualité on va voir on va parler
défense loi de programmation militaire
avec vous maintenant Catherine Bruma
puisque la loi de programmation
militaire c'est en ce moment à
l'Assemblée et vous avez abordé tous ces
sujets c'était lundi lors d'un colloque
au Sénat on voit tout ça avec en tant
qu'elle mais
[Musique]
bonjour Yann bonjour Catherine Dumas
bonjour et Quentin c'est donc un
colloque qui était organisé lundi au
Sénat par la Fondation Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing et c'était l'occasion de poser
les grands enjeux de la loi de
programmation militaire effectivement
dont l'examen a commencé à l'Assemblée
nationale cette semaine effectivement
vous le disiez donc lundi au Sénat ce
sont d'anciens militaires ou encore des
proches des Valéry Giscard d'Estaing qui
étaient réunis ici au Sénat on vous voit
vous étiez également à présent lors de
cette réunion Catherine Dumas l'occasion
d'échanger sur le ce que le quinquennat
de ce président a changé pour nos armées
on a entendu le fils loyer Louis Giscard
d'Estaing expliquer que son père à
l'époque a résolu une crise du moral au
sein des armées quand il arrive à
l'Elysée le président d'alors qui
réalise un important effort budgétaire
le budget des armes mais passe de 2,55%
du PIB en 1974 à 3% à la fin du
quinquennat il en fallait pas plus pour
voir une forme de parallélisme avec la
période que l'on vit actuellement on va
y revenir mais donc certains
intervenants ont insisté sur
l'importance de la souveraineté en
matière d'armement nous ne pouvons pas
être dépendant de puissance étrangères
écoutez Xavier Païta ancien Contre
Amiral dans la marine écoutez-le et
savoir-faire des ingénieurs des
conceptions ou des standards des
architectures d'une grande puissance
pour définir ces systèmes de
commandement
pour moi ça n'est pas compatible avec la
vision qu'à la France de l'emploi de ces
forces armées et donc c'est vraiment un
défi qu'il faut qu'on relève ensemble
avec les armées avec la DGA et ben avec
l'industrie alors la quatrième Dumas
c'était un colloque organisé par la
Fondation Valérie Giscard d'Estaing
question très générale pour commencer
c'était quoi le but de ce coloc au Sénat
la Fondation Giscard d'Estaing organise
un certain nombre de colocs un film tank
en fait pour réfléchir au sujet actuel
évidemment toujours en partant quelque
part de je dirais la pensée de Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing qui pendant sept ans a
quand même marqué la France à une époque
où la France a beaucoup changé aussi
donc voilà et là c'était un colloque
particulièrement sur les sujets de
défense alors il y a eu une partie assez
je dirais sur le passé et on a beaucoup
parlé de collier alors là moi dans une
opération militaire
c'était très intéressant pour montrer
d'ailleurs déjà à l'époque l'efficacité
de l'armée pour intervenir sur des
terrains difficiles etc dans cette
opération à l'époque Congo actuelle
donc c'est assez intéressant par rapport
à ce qui peut se passer aujourd'hui et
puis on a aussi remarqué qu'à l'époque
après on pensait qu'on aurait plus à
faire à deux guerres tout près de chez
nous on s'aperçoit que 2000 km de la
capitale y a une guerre donc ça a permis
la transition et après dans le cadre de
ce coloc mais on est évidemment parlé de
la LPM la loi de programmation militaire
et justement du rôle des industriels et
ça moi je veux aller dans le sens qui a
été
donné par cet amiral la France a une
industrie de défense qui est assez
extraordinaire moi je reviens d'un salon
en Amérique du Sud où on a accompagné
avec une délégation de sénateurs nos
industriels on a un savoir-faire avec
les très grands groupes qui est reconnu
dans le monde entier donc ça c'est
vraiment très important pour la France
et puis pour l'Europe évidemment
puisqu'on en fait profiter nos amis
européens d'ailleurs ajouté que au-delà
des très grands groupes on a des PME des
startups sur en matière défense qui sont
aussi extraordinaires moi j'ai rencontré
une salon à Rio des gens où on voit le
savoir-faire français donc ça il faut le
dire aussi il faut qu'on se l'approprie
et l'idée c'est de bien montrer que
c'est industrie de défense elle est très
importante que dans la loi de
programmation militaire elle va être
bien prise en compte puisque aujourd'hui
on passe à 413 milliards avec cette
nouvelle loi sur 7 ans donc il y a quand
même un réel effort du gouvernement
juste 413 milliards pour vous c'est un
effort historique c'est ce que dit le
gouvernement ça veut dire que vous êtes
bien parti pour la voter cette loi
coûtait je vois pas comment au Sénat on
ne voterait pas cette loi d'abord parce
qu'il faut être responsable il s'agit
juste de notre défense encore une fois
dans un contexte de guerre tout propre
les républicains de l'Assemblée
nationale essayer de retarder le début
de l'examen en faisant une question
priorite préalable au Conseil
constitutionnel ça a été mal vécu ça
parlait à l'air du Sénat vous avez pas
compris la démarche de vos collègues
députés je sais pas certains ont émis
des jugements en tout cas nous c'est pas
notre façon de procéder et je pense pas
qu'on procédera de cette façon oui et
alors vous disiez c'est un effort
important cette cette programmation
militaire est-ce que c'est ces budgets
sont bien fléchés est-ce que cette
souveraineté est si importante de la
France elle est au cœur de cette LPM
selon vous
c'est encore pas le cas on a vu déjà ce
qu'il y a dans le texte c'est évident
que son prix en compte dans
cette vous suffit de demain je pense à
tous les sujets ce qu'on appelle les
sautschnologiques c'est-à-dire la
robotique les drones l'intelligence
artificielle etc exactement la guerre de
demain et celle d'aujourd'hui déjà n'est
pas du tout celle d'hier donc ça je
pense que la LPM le prend bien en compte
il y a aussi le sujet du porte-avion
c'est un porte-avion en nouvelle
génération
un deuxième qui sera opérationnel 2038
donc c'est loin mais le temps de le
faire 10 milliards 5 milliards sur cette
LPM 5 milliards sur une prochaine ça
c'est très important tous les sujets
aussi de de ce qui se passe sur nos
territoires d'outre-mer où on a des
bases très importantes voilà il y a un
gros sujet ça a donné lieu à un débat
d'ailleurs à l'Assemblée c'est la
question de la dissuasion nucléaire
c'est plus de 50 milliards dans cette
loi de programmation militaire il y a eu
un débat parce qu'une partie de la
gauche demande une réflexion sur une
dissuasion de reposant pas sur l'arme
nucléaire je peux vous dire que la
dissuasion nucléaire elle très
importante nous faisons partie des pays
qui disposent de cette dissuasion moi
j'ai récemment participé à une opération
qui s'appelle poker qui est une
opération qui a lieu quatre fois par an
sur le territoire organisé par l'armée
de l'air et qui montre combien la
dissuasion nucléaire d'abord est très
importante parce que d'abord elle permet
de communiquer sur cette force qu'elle a
France et je peux vous dire que quand on
fait cette opération dans les airs comme
une vraie simulation nucléaire avec des
avions chargés non pas de la vraie bombe
nucléaire mais de bombe factice dans les
mêmes conditions tous les pays et amis
ennemis nous regardent ça permet à nos
armées de s'entraîner et ça permet à nos
armées de s'améliorer cette dissuasion
elle est fondamentale évidemment et on a
la chance d'en être doté donc il faut y
consacrer des montants
pour revenir sur le quinquennat de
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing j’évoquais un
parallélisme entre les périodes les 70
avec cette armée qui était démoralisée
et cette investissement massif est-ce
que vous vous le feriez ce avec l'époque
actuelle et effectivement cet effort
conséquent qu'on a vu depuis 2017 ce
milieu de Macron en tout cas moi je ne
trouve pas du tout notre armée
démoralisée et pas du tout parce qu'on
constamment je rencontre des les plus
hauts responsables de l'armée mais aussi
d'ailleurs en allant sur place dans les
régiments différents types de corps
d'armée donc elle est pas du tout
démoralisée en revanche elle a besoin
d'être soutenue par le Parlement qui a
un effort national elle doit être
soutenue par la nation cette armée et je
dirais même pour compléter si un
réarmement matériel dans cette LPM il
faut aussi un réarmement moral
espèrement moral c'est quoi mais c'est
que les Français s'approprient aussi ces
sujets donc il faut qu'on communique
qu'on explique aux Français combien
c'est important pour notre défense pour
notre sécurité la nôtre et celle de nos
partenaires
merci
oui on se retrouve dans le club dans la
deuxième partie de cette émission la
troisième partie de cette émission on
reviendra sur cette info Public Sénat et
le lancement d'une commission d'enquête
sur l'assassinat c'est mieux le patient
2021 ce sera à suivre effectivement tout
à l'heure merci Quentin un mot peut-être
pour faire le lien sur le service
national universel est-ce que pour vous
il faut le généraliser sous la forme
d'un stage de 12 jours pour les élèves
de seconde sur le temps scolaire et ceux
dès la rentrée c'est le projet actuel
c'est le bon projet alors déjà on attend
de savoir ce que le président de la
République veut faire parce que il a
commencé à travailler sur ce sujet et je
trouve dans le quinquennat précédent
notamment et je trouve que c'était une
approche très intéressante puisque
apparemment elle donne de bons résultats
on voit tous ceux qui sont passés par là
sont contents aujourd'hui on nous dit
qu'il sait pas s'il va continuer ou pas
donc déjà moi c'est la question que je
pose qu'est-ce qui va se passer je pense
que il faut travailler sur ces sujets
c'est très très important encore une
fois je parlais en début d'émission du
civisme donc il faut une approche
à quel moment moi je serai plutôt pour
une approche quelque part tout au long
d'une scolarité mais plus qu'une
approche d'ailleurs un vrai
apprentissage de ces sujets après est-ce
qu'il doit y avoir un service national
universel pour l'ensemble des jeunes
pourquoi pas je pense qu'il faut que ça
passe d'abord par du volontariat on peut
pas passer de rien à tout donc il faut
une approche peut-être qui soit
proportionnelle qui qui passe d'abord
par le volontariat quitte à ce que ça
soit généralisé ça marche très bien mais
ce que l'on remarque c'est que tous les
jeunes qui connaissent ces stages qui
restent un mois 15 jours dans le cadre
des armées en sorte en général très très
convaincu et avec plein de belles
expériences donc vraiment je pense que
c'est une belle piste on parle des
sénatoriales que vous êtes sénatrice de
Paris qui fait partie des territoires
renouvelables c'est le 24 septembre on
le rappelle les sénatoriales vous êtes
candidates alors oui je suis candidate
puisque je tête de liste pour le groupe
les républicains à Paris donc il y aura
une liste les républicains évidemment
combien il y aura de liste est-ce que la
droite va partir unie où est-ce que la
droite en train de se diviser non je ne
veux pas dire ça il y a un groupe au
Conseil de Paris quel groupe changer
Paris présidé par Rachida Dati elle a
réussi la performance d'unir 55 élus
premier groupe de l'opposition je le
rappelle premier groupe du Conseil de
Paris d'ailleurs puisqu'on est devant un
groupe socialiste en nombre Rachida Dati
a réussi cette performance d'unir tout
le monde en 2020 et le but c'est quoi
ces 2026 de pouvoir gagner Paris
bien entendu avec notre chef de fil qui
sera aussi notre chef de fil en 2026 là
on est une étape intermédiaire il s'agit
des sénatoriales donc notre groupe a la
capacité avec 55 conseils de paris de
faire quatre sénateurs donc ça c'est
voilà c'est arithmétique on peut faire
quatre sénateurs après vous me dites
qu'est-ce qui va se passer il y a
plusieurs étapes étape 9 juin des grands
électeurs le Conseil de Paris va voter
ses grands électeurs ça sera une
première physionomie pour se rendre
compte les enjeux les comment tout ceci
se met en place après il y aura toutes
les vacances pour travailler et une
élection le 24 septembre avec un dépôt
d'hélice sénatorial je le rappelle tout
début septembre donc voyez le temps est
long aujourd'hui il y a des discussions
voilà mais avec qui parce que là
actuellement vous êtes quatre sénateurs
il y en a trois qui souhaitent se
représenter qui souhaiteraient se
représenter il y a vous il y a Pierre
Charon il y a Céline voulait esperanier
est-ce que vous serez tous les trois sur
la même liste alors ça m'est difficile
de répondre ce que je veux juste dire et
pour que tout le monde comprenne c'est
que pour être sénateur de Paris il y a
quand même une première exigence c'est
d'être membre du Conseil de Paris sinon
c'est quand même très très compliqué
puisque c'est un microcosme où se trouve
les voies donc si vous êtes à
l'extérieur du Conseil de Paris c'est le
cas des deux collègues que vous avez
cités Pierre-Charron et Céline voulait
lesperonnier depuis 2020
ne sont plus au Conseil de Paris il
était auparavant ils étaient sénateurs
aujourd'hui ne le sont plus donc je
pense que c'est une grande difficulté
pour eux d'être sénateur enfin en tout
cas d'être candidat donc ils ne sont pas
prévus sur votre liste à l'heure alors
en ce qui concerne Céline Boulley non
parce que je pense que toute façon elle
est plus proche d'autres groupes que le
elle est apparentée au Sénat et pas du
tout dans le groupe LR et donc si vous
voulez il ne fait pas partie de DLR donc
en ce qui la concerne ou voilà ce que je
peux dire après moi je peux pas non plus
dire ce que font mes collègues sénateurs
d'aujourd'hui et en ce qui concerne
pierre Charente nous lui avons proposé
d'être sur la liste que je vais conduire
pour l'instant les choses n'ont pas
abouti donc pour le moment votre liste
elle serait composée de qui en tout cas
pour les trois premiers
puisque vous savez qu'il y a une
première discussion qui est très
importante puisque le Sénat évidemment
compte beaucoup dans le choix des sén
entre le président du Sénat bien entendu
et le président de mon groupe Bruno
Retailleau ce qui était décédé
aujourd'hui c'est je conduise la liste
que mon numéro 2 soit le maire du 16e
arrondissement Francis piner et que le
numéro 3 soit Marie-Claire Kerger une
élue du 14e arrondissement qui
représenterait l'Est parisien qui est
très important pour nous pour la
reconquête et qui sont tous les deux
évidemment membres du Conseil de Paris
avec un risque de liste dissidente
Céline Boulle espéronier nous disait
qu'elle était prête à monter sa propre
liste écoutez tout le monde peut et bien
entendu et je vais certainement pas
empêcher mes collègues de dire ça hein
de le dire mais bon en ce qui la
concerne je pense que ça nous empêchera
pas du tout d'avoir nos quatre sièges
sur votre liste à vous soyez sur lui
est-ce que le fait que la gauche devrait
partir unie tout le monde sur la même
vie ça vous inquiète est-ce que là ça
pourrait vous faire perdre des sièges
moi je suis pas du tout inquiète parce
que fait la gauche parce qu'encore une
fois au sein du Conseil de Paris les
équilibres sont tout à fait répartis on
les connaît ils vont pas changer et il y
a peut-être quelques voix de grands
électeurs qui se promèneront mais si
vous voulez les équilibres sont fixés et
donc on sait où on va et encore une fois
nous nous avons les voix pour faire
quatre sénateurs et ensuite tout ça
merci beaucoup merci Catherine Dumas
merci à vous d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin dans 20 minutes dans le club des
territoires on viendra sur actualités
politiques de la semaine notamment la
bataille qui se joue entre l'exécutif et
l'opposition sur la loi d'abrogation de
la réforme des retraites curatives ou
non un débat le 8 juin on en parle dans
le club d'abord on va parler de la
guerre en Ukraine c'est Sylvie Berman
qui nous rejoint